We don’t know about you, but here on the
Microcosmos team, we find it hard not to smile
as we watch tardigrades with their cute, pitch-black
eyes and little feet ambling across the smooth
glass surface of the microscope slide.
Moss piglets, water bears—whatever you call
them, they’re fascinating to watch, and
even more fascinating to try and understand.
They are a puzzle, and we humans are the puzzler.
And so we figured, sure, we’ve already focused
on tardigrades in a previous episode.
But we cannot possibly leave it there.
After all, like the microscopic world around
them, tardigrades always have more to show us.
Our water bears are collected from ponds and
growing moss, environments that give them
the water and food they need to thrive.
And so, behind the scenes, we like to give
them a bit of attention, making sure that
they are well fed and comfortable in their
slides.
After all, a drop of water is barely anything
to us, but to a tardigrade, a thing so tiny
and so good at surviving, that drop can be
everything.
Tardigrades of course live their lives, absent
of any kind of intention to teach us anything.
They don’t even know we’re here.
But watching is a form of interaction, and
one that reveals the interface between the
micro, the macro, and even the cosmic.
So let’s start with a part of the tardigrade
body whose weirdness we haven’t had the
chance to fully appreciate here yet: their
mouths.
The opening of the tardigrade mouth is a distinct
ring, giving way to a tube that connects to
the pharyngeal bulb, which helps the tardigrade
suction out the juicy contents of its meal.
But to get to the juice, the tardigrade first
needs to pierce its target, relying on a pair
of stylets that poke out of the mouth ring
when it comes time to feed.
When the tardigrade molts, they shed their
stylets and replace them with a new pair.
Tardigrades are omnivorous, they’re open
to eating bacteria, plants, and animals.
For some species, their meal might even be
another tardigrade.
But for the species here, our samples contain
plenty of algae and plant matter for them
to dine on, collected from the same watery
and earthy worlds as the tardigrades these
bits of organic matter keep them well fed
like a built-in buffet.
But there are other times where bearing witness
to the microcosmos takes a little more adaptation
on our part.
Recently, we found a water bear with its half-shed
cuticle filled with eggs, still attached to
its body in what amounts to parenting in the
microcosmos.
As you might imagine, we were more than a
little curious to watch these eggs develop.
But if you keep a slide on a microscope for
too long, the water will evaporate, taking
with it the moisture the tardigrade needs
to exist outside of its dessicated, dormant state.
So we kept these slides in humidity chambers
and took extra care to make sure the coverslip
wouldn’t crush the developing tardigrades.
And then…we watched.
The tardigrade though was still.
This video is from our sixth day of observation, the only sign of life being the absence of decomposition.
Three days later, we can see the eggs are
developing, and there are even little tardigrade
heads appearing.
The mother still seems the same, attached
to her eggs and seemingly still alive despite
her complete stillness.
When it comes time to hatch, the embryos
will use their stylets and pharyngeal pump
to make their way out, sucking in water to
increase the pressure on the egg from the inside
until the shell breaks.
But…we’re still waiting for that day to
come with this tardigrade brood.
Embryonic development in tardigrade can last
from 5 days to more than 100, varying by species
and dependent on environmental factors like
temperature.
The thing with biology, no matter what scale
of creature you’re looking at, is that you’re
always on their schedule, not the other way
around.
Food and birth probably seem a bit domestic
compared to some of the more recent tardigradian
exploits you may have heard about.
Earlier in 2019, Israel sent a spacecraft
called Beresheet to the moon, taking with
it, among many things, a digital archive of
almost the entirety of English Wikipedia and
also thousands of tardigrades, dried out in
their ball-like tun form and ready for lift off.
Seconds before Beresheet was supposed to land,
however, it lost contact with Mission control
and crashed instead, leaving one very obvious
question: what will happen to those thousands
of tardigrades, potentially spilled across
the surface of the moon.
Our seeming penchant for sending tardigrades
into space has taught us that they’re able
to tolerate vacuums.
Without liquid water, of course, the tardigrades
will remain in their dormant state.
Maybe if someone is able to return to that
crash site decades from now, they might manage
to find tardigrades that survived that crash,
and there’s a chance that with a little
water, they could come back to life.
We’re still working to understand all of
the tricks of tardigrade survival, how does
it play out in their DNA and proteins, and
why some tardigrade species seem to be better
than others.
This is part of the fun of tardigrades and
our collective fascination with them.
We’re all learning together here on planet
earth, like a giant science classroom, asking
important questions like, “Is that round
thing the mouth?” and “What does happen
when you put a tardigrade on the moon?”
Maybe this is our 21st century remix of Apollo,
a conversation between microcosmos and good
old-fashioned cosmos.
Science is ultimately a mix of deliberate
and accidental questions, taking on many forms
to suit our available tools.
Sometimes science is a detailed study, and
sometimes it’s a crash landing.
It can be a collector of microbes and a master
of microscopes, carefully tending to samples
to meet the needs of their invisible residents.
And sometimes it’s you, watching along,
making your own observations, maybe even thinking
of new questions that no one has ever thought to ask before.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you to all of these patrons.
All of these wonderful people who it possible for us to take care of our microscopic friends
and bring you these videos once a week here on Journey to the Microcosmos.
If you want to see more from our Master of Microscopes, James,
check out Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, we've got a lot of videos up now.
Check em out at youtube.com/microcosmos.